lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
preguntarnos qué propiedades de una
figura se conservan y cuáles no al
aplicar una transformación rígida en
particular vamos a pensar en reflexiones
y rotaciones en este vídeo y ambas son
transformaciones rígidas lo que
significa que la longitud entre dos
puntos cualesquiera no cambia por
ejemplo imagina que tomamos este círculo
que tiene centro en amd y lo vamos a
rotar alrededor del punto p
el punto p es el centro de la rotación
imagina que lo hacemos en dirección de
las manecillas del reloj y terminamos en
este punto de acá acá tendremos el nuevo
centro del círculo y podemos dibujarlo
después de la rotación el nuevo círculo
se va a ver así
es un dibujo a mano así que perdona la
falta de precisión bien ahora pensemos
en las cosas que se conservan en este
caso hicimos una rotación que es una
transformación rígida y las cosas que se
conservan son primero observa la
longitud del radio déjame notarlo la
longitud del radio la longitud del radio
aquí era de 2 y por acá la longitud del
radio también es de 2 otra cosa que se
conserva es el perímetro si el radio de
un círculo se conservan entonces el
perímetro del círculo que llamaremos
circunferencia es una función del radium
recuerda es 2 por pi por el radio por lo
tanto el perímetro también se conserva
de nuevo todo esto sale de que se
conserva el radio y si se conserva el
radio también se conservará el área
recuerda área es igual a pi por radio al
cuadrado así que todo esto se conserva y
estoy seguro de que esto te hace sentir
bien
ahora qué es lo que no se conserva ojo
todo esto es en general cierto para
todas las transformaciones rígidas que
conservan la distancia entre dos puntos
correspondientes si transformamos
cualquier figura se conservará el área y
el perímetro también se conservan cosas
como los ángulos pero lo que no se
conservan son las coordenadas del centro
de los puntos correspondientes a veces
suele pasar pero no siempre por ejemplo
la coordenada del centro en este caso
cambia vamos del punto menos 30 a acá
donde estamos en menos 12 déjame
terminar de escribir las coordenadas del
centro
ahora qué te parece si hacemos otro
ejemplo con otra figura distinta y otra
transformación distinta
esta vez hagamos una reflexión para eso
vamos a tomarnos el cuadrilátero a bs
dem y pensemos en que se conserva y que
no se conserva cuando hacemos una
reflexión sobre la recta el bueno qué te
parece si hacemos la reflexión muy
rápido si reflejo sobre la recta que
iguala x lo que esencialmente hacemos es
cambiar las coordenadas x sigue pero no
es necesario que se pase esto para ver
este vídeo entonces ve prima estaría por
aquí por acá estaría a prima por acá
estaría de prima y como se está sobre el
eje de reflexión entonces ser se quedará
en el mismo lugar así que nuestra nueva
figura reflejada sobre la recta l será
ésta que estoy dibujando pero no
forzosamente tenías que saber cómo se
hace esta reflexión tan rápido lo único
que hice es ver cómo se vería la
reflexión
porque esto nos ayudará a saber que se
conserva recuerda el tema central de
este vídeo es saber qué pasa al aplicar
transformaciones rígidas bien que se
conserva bueno en cualquier
transformación rígida se conservan la
longitud en este caso la longitud de los
lados de hecho esta es una forma de
definir una transformación rígida ante
una transformación que conserva la
longitud entre los puntos también
conservamos las medidas de los ángulos
por ejemplo aquí el ángulo am va a ser
el mismo al que ahora tenemos aquí en a
prima de igual manera la distancia entre
a y b será la misma que la distancia
entre a prima y be prima también se
conserva el perímetro si tienes los
mismos lados y los mismos ángulos el
perímetro se conservará y también el
área de igual manera que la rotación
ambas son transformaciones rígidas y
estas son las cosas que se conservan en
las transformaciones rígidas
ahora que no se conserva igual que en el
otro ejemplo las coordenadas no se
conservan como puedes ver las
coordenadas de amd son distintas que las
deja prima de igual manera para ver y ve
prima 6 se prima si comparten las mismas
coordenadas pero fue un caso especial
porque se está sobre el eje de reflexión
pero de iu de prima cambian de
coordenadas así que déjame ponerlo las
coordenadas en este caso de ave y de ok
y déjame poner por acá arriba que la
coordenada desee en este caso si se
conservó ahora observa lo siguiente el
lado cede era paralelo al eje james y
cuando le aplicamos la transformación se
prima de prima ahora no lo es de hecho
ahora es paralelo al eje x eso quiere
decir que algunas cosas relacionadas
fuera de la transformación al aplicar la
transformación puede que tampoco se
conserven en fin espero que este vídeo
te haya ayudado hasta la próxima